[Music]
cheater cheater news a cheater punkin
here submitted by Hawaii's state fish
home of home one new kanou-kun no app
walk oh I can't dad on it it's dead-on
accurate its actual exactly why no
Hawaiians I'm about the first time you
should we as soon as I read it the first
time you you had it for dinner that's
true I did eat two men tried to cheat in
a pigeon race what the [ __ ] is
appearance you race pigeons me throw
them as far as you can we should get
pigeons and paint them brown with a
little white - is that the top and turn
it chuckles thing oh that's good alright
the cooks at our restaurant
they were like into pigeon racing and
they would train their pigeons and then
they would let them out like from their
car and they would drive like with the
pigeon to a certain area where they
trained them to go down yeah well
they're just like hey I'm in the pigeon
racing we're talking about gambling oh
okay you gamble and do that and but
they're like on the weekends they just
train their pigeons and [ __ ] two men to
try to cheat in a pigeon race by
transporting the birds via bullet train
yeah holy [ __ ] that's amazing
is that really faster though yeah is it
faster I love rigging a pigeon race is
it really fast talking about rigging a
pigeon I feel like it is this is all
really good so far highs no but it'll be
too fast though cuz what bullet trains
go like couple hundred miles per hour
some [ __ ] I don't think a pigeon could
go that fast but pigeons can go directly
from point A to point B
train you gotta follow that route and
then exit and then still drive to
wherever you go so we did it really help
yes spill the deets no it didn't they
got caught listening yeah I caught
cheating could they get caught after
they want
yeah they win first and then get caught
and they tested the pigeon for steroids
and they realize it was bullet train
fumes they tested the pigeons for
steroids but in so doing they killed the
pigeons I said I was yeah using a needle
alright so this takes place in China of
course of course
pigeon racing is pretty big out there so
the prize money was a hundred and sixty
US dollars that's like probably more
than the [ __ ] train ride yeah
a little bit more 160,000 holy geez I
get why they're independent what a
[ __ ] corner - bullet train - like six
figures yes Wow
they take a [ __ ] series I'm gonna stare
160 I would take it seriously - and they
gamble like so there's more money that
goes on - oh yeah dude yeah so these two
men they rigged a bird race usually
pigeons like they're raised in one place
and then they're trained to fly over to
the another place but the way that they
rigged it was that they raised these
pigeons in two places at once and so
when the race started they let him go
from the initial place but then instead
of flying to the end of the line they
flew to the second location and that's
where they picked up these pigeons and
then they took a bullet train they won
by like way too much because they were
way faster than the other birds
you know weighted than birdly possible
how did they know that they took a
bullet train they're like six hours
early I bet on that
we just thought of the race 15 minutes
ago
and we're 300 miles away houses possible
while the tsunamis going on yeah it
would take about eight hours but they
got there in three hours and oh god
they're [ __ ] so stupid they're
setting up the finish line tape I want
these guys to win that's the thing that
sucks is like I wanted them to win I
always want them to win yeah I do too
when I'm watching the movie I want the
criminal to win it depends if you're
smart them nor Duncan that's true
is it because our wedding like that like
you know when you bet on boxing like you
bet like the first round second round so
it's like based off time like if you can
beat them in the first three hours or
first four hours maybe you it was just
impossible though because like there's
no way there's a bullet pigeon that
exists like there's just no way that
that pigeon would have made it there
without cheating I see yeah that's way
too fast that's like from San Francisco
to LA on a bicycle in one hour yeah it's
just impossible yeah so they're saying
that these pigeons fly about the same
speed as like a car would dry it's like
an f-14 J they're all so stupid because
they could be like wait a min
if they got here really early let me see
how they actually flow and then they can
go back to destination one and then
they're gonna see that these dumbass
pigeons fly to destination two before
making it out right what if these
pigeons are like athlete pigeons and
like after they're done they put their
sandals on right and they can't really
perform another one without getting paid
like you can't get LeBron James ago oh
you see that dunk
let me see you dead one more time that's
LeBron James animals yeah but these
aren't LeBron pigeons they're probably
not down to do stuff like like LeBron
knew the good feathers yeah I like a
little duffel bag wouldn't these cats
just get their 45 minutes early because
they're stupid good if they just waited
like a couple hours and then let them go
I'm glad they got caught so the court
showed them leniency because they was so
stupid we were so happy and laughing so
no because they confessed so as soon as
the other pigeon racers they were like
what the [ __ ] that there's no way they
could have won right so then that's an E
confess they're like all right but they
ended up smashing these pigeons against
the ground and kill them so they were
destroying the evidence not LeBron
pigeon yeah both of these pigeons yeah
both of the they destroyed the evidence
but they did admit and they did savages
to you and they didn't claim the prize
or else that would have been way worse
so if they did get caught after the fact
that they took the prize that would have
been a big travel I mean they did get in
trouble is just that they're saying like
we're not gonna punish you you're not
gonna serve any time unless you get
punished for a different crime then
that's when they're gonna they're like
here's a warning yeah pretty much it's
pretty much like a warning they smash
those little pigeons man kill dumber
destroy the evidence
all you were doing were following the
rules so how is the pigeon evidence if
it just flew because they could probably
figure out like the flight yeah but its
condition to stop it yeah oh I see so
they just haven't fly again they see
where they go anyway we know that
information they're stupid yeah they're
just acting on impulse holy [ __ ]
BAM you know
poor buddy poor little buddy they smash
them on the ground no I just picture
them no you know what they should do for
pigeon races what's really cool is they
have this tracker for like smarten race
where if you run and then every like
marker they tell you like what your time
is oh and they should kind of put like a
little new diaper marathon yes it's the
same thing I think it's called athletes
or something like that and when the
pigeons go you can see your time the
pigeon time I'll be I'll be pretty cool
do a harness 60 G's you charter a
helicopter but the helicopter might like
suck up the pigeons if you [ __ ] draw
desert spot then you put the pitches in
little cage where carrier oh you mean
cheating oh I thought you meant like I
would attract their flight ya know cuz i
was thinkin of a legit pigeon race with
like drones following and like announcer
and then it's like thank you cuz this is
like so boring you just let it go and
you wait for the pigeons to come in this
is just like pigeon whines in the lead
pigeon - that's what I want to see you
but that's really boring cuz they're
just going in the sky there's no real
obstacle yeah you can't watch it what's
kinda like horse races pretty boy come
on golf I'm like how the [ __ ] do they
attract that boy but the camera always
gets right on that ball I'm always like
damn so they can attract that ball they
could track a pigeon yeah especially now
I forgot to mention - and they took on
the bullet train like it's illegal to
put live animals in the bullet train so
they stuffed them in milk cartons
oh my god these four [ __ ] pigeons
dude [ __ ] Chinese people but it's a
hundred and sixty thousand dollar carton
thing is less of a bummer to me is oh
the whole thing is a bummer yeah the
whole thing's covered well what if this
is like a rec center that they're saving
the rec center to save the rec center
you know he's doing this for the orphans
that's mine I just wish nothing had to
die I know save the [ __ ] rec center
let them fly away and be on their merry
way they did the Potter part of the
[ __ ] contribution I
I feel like if you dangle that kind of
money
around poor people though it's just any
[ __ ] up [ __ ]
poor Chinese people - yeah cuz they more
time for us do did Reggie get everything
everyone like horse races yeah they try
to cheat during that shit's true like
everybody like I don't know if there's
one support where people don't try to
cheat him due to [ __ ] horses
racehorse tell me know if you turn
anything into a sport and then you bring
money into the equation yes like any
sort of profitable thing like we were
talking about the donkey's that that
like they wouldn't change their saddle
and [ __ ] they're all pretty black people
on the donkeys yeah yeah over wire
you're an NFL - there's like PD people
get popped for peds stuff for
performance-enhancing drugs steroid [ __ ]
that's an all sport yeah cuz it's so
competitive like it's like did you watch
it gross the Netflix documentary oh no
you should be pretty crazy crazy and
amateur sports it's almost like people
they have to in order to be top ten to
compete yeah it's actually way more in
amateur sports because it's not as
regulated because there's less
regulation so it's people that I don't
know why what it is but like because
there's less regulation and I think
they'll never get to the pros they want
to dominate in that realm so there's so
much more that happens in amateur sports
I wish target-shooting was cool to watch
cuz it's not but that's what would be
the hardest thing that you didn't mean
like Olympic yeah like this this the
pistol shooting oh yeah that cool watch
that one you can't really cheat on they
have peds for stuff like that too now it
really focus yeah reactions I knew that
we could cheat at anything human being
Anderson Silva got popped for his after
he broke his shin they said it wasn't
even for muscle recovery was actually
for a reaction time because it's such a
big part of his fight game to be able to
kind of like like be Roy Jones jr. and
like like move around so his fight game
he took peds that were specific for the
style of fight that he does wait there's
reaction time drugs yeah okay if you can
see your opponent do something before he
even does it like you already beat them
is there something that can help me
focus on [ __ ]
aw dude try kids it's really great but
that's just men
oh yeah right let's miss good for you
it's it's the same chemical of life
that's good it's synthesized meth it's
meant but it's not good for you no it's
so good for you
meditation method Asian you've job did
it oh why you make it [ __ ] I was gonna
have your back
Steve outdid like acid in all times he
did acid back in the day Duras new
adderall does work though I've never had
it
[Music]